so i i'm not gonna lie i feel kind of
buried in work right now i've got a lot
of long-term projects i'm trying to get
taken care of some major video editing
that i'm trying to do trying to finish
the edit on the audio book of my novel
because i really want to get that out as
soon as possible and i want to get all
that done without cutting back on any of
the stuff that i normally do so this
video i feel like i need to do something
simpler and not as complicated and just
take things a little bit easier
so we're going to be talking about
auteur theory what it is what people
have problems with about it and
dissecting the discussions both correct
and incorrect around it
i feel i may have made an error
[Music]
so a random note a little bit into this
video i'm gonna suddenly change outfits
uh because um
something went really weird with my
memory card and the video file corrupted
i got to keep a lot of it but not the
front end of explaining what the heck it
is i'm doing here so auteur theory is
something that relates to
the collaborative artistic projects
primarily film even though it has in
time since been applied to other mediums
i'd say video games is where i see the
term come up more often you don't see it
as much in something like theater or
television because those are often
viewed more as
writer focused mediums whereas film is
specifically a director focused medium
or at least that's what auteur theory
says so here's the short version of what
auteur theory is and then i'll talk
about
some of the discourse i hear around it
that really drives me off the wall and
then we'll actually start to pull it
apart
the short version of what auteur theory
is
it states that the director of a film is
the person with the most creative
control and the loudest creative voice
because they are the ones who are
directing the whole project and it is
their vision that everyone else's work
is in service of and they are therefore
generally for analysis purposes
under auteur theory considered to be
the author
of the finished work
so that's the theory in a nutshell
here's what kind of annoys me because
like this
weirdly this has come up in like a
handful of podcasts that i've been
listening to lately from people who like
i respect
and they've like
i've seen some of them rail against
auteur theory and they seem to
fundamentally not understand what it
actually is there's this weird straw man
version of auteur theory that i actually
see and hear a fair number of people
like rail against
except
what they're arguing is not what it is
so let me deal with that first off
because that's kind of what kicked this
whole thing off
what auteur theory
is not
is a theory that states nobody matters
except the director
because a lot of time when i hear people
rail against the idea of auteur theory
and let's be clear there are some
problems with the application of auteur
theory we'll get to those later but what
i see people rail against is they're
like oh nobody else made a difference
none of all these other people's work
matters all of it matters auteur theory
is elitist and it disregards the work of
other people and
no
no it doesn't
it attributes primary guidance to a
single person but it does not actually
say nobody else matters and i think part
of the confusion is honestly just a
quirk of language because auteur is
related to the word author and when we
think author we tend to think of books
and books and novels and things of that
nature are a medium in which one person
is pretty much solely responsible even
though that's a little bit of a
collaborative medium as well because you
have editors who come in to try and make
the book the best that it's going to
possibly be you have everything from
layout line editors you have the
publishers involved you heck the person
who designs the cover there are other
people involved but it is generally
agreed and appreciated that when you
look at a book there's this one person's
name in big bold letters under or
sometimes over the title
that's the author
and when people
rail against auteur theory the sense i
get is that they're trying to apply that
image of an author and think that auteur
theory is saying that's what they are
like
everything about this basically comes
down to them and the other people don't
matter
that's
not what auteur theory is
so
what is auteur theory actually let's
drill into it a little bit
because as i said it doesn't disregard
anyone else's work
what it says
is that the director of a film
is the person going to be most
responsible for the shape and form of
the final product a director's vision a
director's interpretation of the script
and their leading of the overall team
towards a single cohesive final artistic
product is going to have the most
determination on the end result in other
words
if you were to change the director but
leave everything else in place every
actor same script same crew same
everything but change the director you
will still most likely end up with two
very different films because the
directors come in with different visions
conversely if you keep the director but
swap out anybody else whether it be
makeup artist set direction script
editor
lighting designer key grip
even a lead actor
while things will be slightly different
not identical
it will still take the same overall
shape
it will still be for the most part the
same final product and will not deviate
anywhere near as much as if you were to
change out the director it doesn't mean
no one else's contributions matter it
just means that the final result is more
the product of the director strictly
creatively not logistically
obviously a director isn't doing
everything themselves but it the final
product takes the shape that it does
because of the director maybe it would
be illustrated for me to name some
notable auteur directors people who
bring very specific very clear visions
thematic preferences or just an overall
tone and feel to their work that makes
them immediately identifiable by their
directing style choices and vision so
this would be people like alfred
hitchcock stanley kubrick
zack snyder christopher nolan quentin
tarantino guillermo del toro these are
people who once you are familiar with
their work you could see a movie
directed by them and probably realize
they were the ones who directed it even
if no one told you in advance they have
very clear preferences notions ways of
presenting framing things and vision
that they bring to the works they make
now not every director is an author
director the other side of the coin
there is what is charitably usually
called a journeyman director someone who
while they are certainly competent and
can make good or even great films they
don't bring a unique authorial voice to
it because there are frankly some
directors who you could swap out with
another director who is also a
journeyman director and you would end up
with effectively the same product so
while auteur theory says that the
director is the primary creative force
of a film
it does not mean that every director is
an auteur it simply means that the
position of director has that potential
if an auteur is in that position
so not only is there the aspect of
journeyman directors or if you're
looking at an unskilled and uh just bad
version of someone who doesn't have a
particularly unique vision that's where
you get a hack
but even aside from that we also live in
a world at this point where other forces
may have more control than the director
in a specific thing the director might
not have final cut in which case it
might actually be some studio head that
could be said to shape it more than
anyone else there are situations where
films are produced by one of the lead
actors and that actor actually has more
influence over the overall direction of
the thing because they also carry a
producer credit than whoever the
director is i would argue that that's
been the case for the last handful of
mission impossible movies but the big
thing to keep in mind here is that while
the director holds
potentially the most creative influence
that doesn't invalidate anyone else's
contributions it doesn't mean the uh
director could have done it without
anybody else's help it doesn't say they
did it all on their own it just says
that they steered the ship the ship is
fully crewed and you need that full crew
but the captain is the one deciding
where that goes the director is the
captain
so
that is what auteur theory actually is
and why that argument that i tend to
hear against it seems to come to a
fundamental misunderstanding of what
auteur theory actually is
so now that we've talked about what
author theory is
what's wrong with it
because
i do actually think there are some very
legitimate discussions to be had about
problems with auteur theory at least in
practice if not to the theory itself
but they don't seem to be happening
because people get hung up on a
misunderstanding of what the theory even
is
so now that we hopefully have a shared
understanding of what it actually is
what's the problem
well
this largely comes down to
for lack of a better way to put it
people buying into their own hype
as a strictly creative theory element
in terms of academic analysis and study
of films and filmmakers
ultra theory on itself is just a framing
through which to view
a film
or possibly some other forms of
collaborative art
but when put in practice
when brought into the common lexicon
when it gets into somebody's head
that they are on auteur
or when a studio believes that the
director at the helm of their film
is an auteur
that is where a lot
of
some of the most toxic
harmful and deplorable
actions on movie sets
tend to root from
most stories that you've heard of
terrible
film shoots or of directors who have
mistreated
their stars their crew or anybody like
that
the vast majority of the time
it comes from directors
who either are considered by people
broadly to be our tours or who clearly
consider themselves to be on our tour
and actually it's worth pointing out at
this point that being on our tour does
not actually make you good at what you
do
over bowl is an auteur he has a very
distinct style and vision and approach
to his films and it is very clear that
they would have looked very different in
the hands of any other director they're
not
good but they are uniquely his he is an
auteur
being an author doesn't make you
good
at what you do it doesn't make the end
product good
it just means it would have been
different under somebody else and if you
want the most current relevant example i
think that would probably be
joss whedon
who i'm not thrilled to have to talk
about again did a whole freaking thing
on him not too long ago but
he is a person who has a very clear
voice and style some might argue that
it's more as a writer than as a director
as a crafter of visuals but since he
writes his own scripts
he is as a writer director
actually in even more control than just
a director would be and he certainly has
writing styles and quirks and visions
and things that are fairly unique to his
approach to things that's i think pretty
undeniable
and i think it's pretty clear that he
seemed to have considered himself an
auteur
but more importantly he was treated as
one
by studios
who would be alerted to his treatment of
people
underneath him
on his tv shows and then later on his
films ultimately blowing up on the set
of the reshoots of justice league
and the studios would protect and shield
him
and i think part of the reason they do
that
is because
auteur theory has become so embedded in
the creative process especially in
hollywood
that the studios if they think they have
a good auteur director unless they think
that person has completely derailed the
project
they will keep them in place and protect
them because the studio thinks that the
auteur director is the least replaceable
person and there are definitely
directors who think that about
themselves
and that
goes way way back i cited joss whedon as
a modern example but this is not new
kubrick
was not a good person to work for
he would take literally a hundred takes
of the exact same shot nearly identical
every time because it wasn't precisely
what he wanted and it was allowed and
excused because he was seen as an author
visionary
i would argue he was a jackass who was
wasting everybody's time and money and
if you want to take a specific example
i
will never be okay
with anyone who ever
makes the argument
that how he treated shelley duvall on
the set of the shining was okay
because he emotionally and
psychologically abused her deliberately
because he thought it would get a better
performance out of her he put his art as
being more important than her personal
mental and even physical health
and no
no
even if you like that movie i don't i
hate that movie but even if you like it
don't ever defend how he treated her
anywhere near me
because i will jump down your throat
and not in a fun way but not to dwell on
kubrick for too long alfred hitchcock
amazing director
the father of entire genres of film
masterful films like films that i love
oh my god was he a horrible stuck-up
creep of a human being
it was allowed because
well he's alfred hitchcock
he's going to get us
this amazing movie at the end let him do
whatever his process is
because he's the one we need to get this
to end up
as the film we want
and there's plenty of other examples
all over the place
now it's worth pointing out
and i think actually emphasizing not all
auteurs are like this
i mentioned zack snyder in my list of
auteurs and i do definitely think the
man is auteur and he's also a man who
makes very few films that i enjoy
i dislike most of his movies
but you know what
everything i've ever heard
or read about him and his on-set
behavior
is that he's an absolute delightful
person to work with
people really like working with him
that includes actors cinematographers
people on set
the crew
he's a nice guy
by every measure i can possibly find
regardless of what you think of his
films regardless of what you think his
personal politics are
he runs a professional and pleasant
set with a nice working environment
so i don't want you to think that all
auteurs
are terrible people
but
at the heart of most disasters of film
both artistically and in terms of how
people were treated on set
there is almost always
an auteur with an ego
at the heart of it
and that's where i kind of want to cycle
into
video games
so the thing about the video game
industry is
the industry as a whole doesn't really
put up with auteurs they don't like them
because the video game industry has
become as massively monumentally
staggeringly successful as it has
by standardizing things by having
standard practices having systems using
algorithms to figure out what drives
engagement and what gets people to spend
money in the micropayment shop
so an auteur is potentially a wrench
into that if someone has a unique
creative vision for a video game how do
we know they're gonna put all the things
the algorithm and the spreadsheet says
should be there
so
you would think there wouldn't be a lot
of auteurs in video games
but there are
if you follow video games if you know
video games you know names like
ken levine
john romero shigeru miyamoto suda 51
sweary toby fox jonathan blow
and if you know these names you might
have noticed that i started to go into
indie video game makers towards the end
because
well yeah
it's something that is more tolerated
within the indie sphere but
this was the other thing that got me
thinking about this and wanting to talk
about it
folks should know at this point that the
video game industry as a whole
has a lot
of deeply rooted problems again
something i've talked about before
and while
those problems are probably most
embedded and most
prevalent
in what is known as the aaa video game
development
i.e the very big budget very high end
realistic looking graphics fully
rendered huge games it is really across
the industry and there have been news
items in the last few weeks about a lot
of indie
creators a lot of indie studios who are
small enough to have
individuals at the head of them who are
treated like auteurs
and who are protected
regardless of how they treat their
employees
and that i think is
what has been the actual damage
of auteur theory is in
the behavior of a
the people who believe themselves to be
auteurs and that
being the primary creative author of a
work gives them
priority as a human being
over those around them
and two the studios
and corporate entities who reinforce
that by behavior if not
statement because when i was explaining
auteur theory earlier i said that you
could theoretically replace anyone who
isn't the director and you'll still have
largely the same product at the end and
while
i said that because
that's how the theory works and i do
think there is some amount of truth in
that to
take that on board too much
means that
the auteur
and the studio supporting them
do actually start to treat people as
disposable
as replaceable
not as
people
and that
is the damage of auteur theory
not because the theory itself is bad or
even inaccurate i largely agree with it
especially when it comes to a
medium-like film
but the
prevalence of it
the way that it has shaped the behavior
of not only directors but the people who
have the ability to hold those directors
accountable and choose not to because
they think they're protecting an auteur
yeah that
that's a problem
and that's a conversation worth having
definitely much more so than this idea
of well auteur theory says nobody else
matters no it doesn't
have the actual conversation
not that nonsense
because that's not what's going on
that's not what the theory says and
that's not the problem so there you have
it
my rambles
on auteur theory
what do you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it patreon's how i'm able to
pay the bills and uh try and get all the
other stuff that i'm trying to get done
done
because i definitely wouldn't be doing
i'd say uh two-thirds of what i do
if i had to hold down a day job so that
is immensely helpful even if you can't
support me there
like share subscribe also help me out
but don't worry about it too much what i
really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings
i don't think i consider myself a
youtube auteur
but regardless until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and credits i gotta shout out my top
patreon supporters so thank you very
much to zubin luthfulla barack oliver
bean melinda walters lyotha boy tt for
knobby lax the poodle idol tracy
scrabbat vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor shane ross
robin moore shayla gourley and brendan
the rose
couldn't do it without you
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]